good morning gamers we're back in
Minecraft isn't right right Sven there's
one thing I've been wanted to try for so
long in Sven go in the minecart cuz that
would be pretty epic spend it please
you're scaring me you're scaring the
kids Sven come down thank you no stop I
get in spend get in spend get in the
minecart oh my god
[Music]
Oh
wait for me Hey
I will that answers that question better
stops ahead
oh god is ena forever loop oh these
stairs are awful if you don't have the
minecart so bad I'm Cobb a god is there
anything you can't do how was that sweat
did you like that you want to go again
okay here we go spin go hey Bob say all
right while Sven goes on a little roller
coaster we have other important stuff to
do I think today I really just want to
focus on building because that's a big
part of the Minecraft ship ship ship
show sheets shop and I haven't really
done it and I just really feel like
doing it so we're gonna build that
something special today and I think it's
gonna be pretty fun I think it's gonna
be pretty epic
stop growing I told you to stop so we're
gonna need some wool because we're
obviously gonna decorate IKEA Tower as
one of the things of course of course
why has not spend returned oh geez I
think literally all my mine carts are
down there
Oh God's man watch out
Oh eat eat eat eat damn I hate them ruin
my flooring and they hurt Sven I can't
do this how can you live just to give
other people pain all right we have the
minecarts all right so now we push then
and then this will push here we go
we're under attack
we're under attack no no no no you can't
eat me he wet again
so then can you stop I mean state
staying there be a good boy and I put
this and we yes yes yes yes yes all
right that's enough fun that's enough
fun for now Finn
just keep feeding Sven that's all we
need to do remember kids if spend eyes
playthrough over
no more I refuse to play okay so I got
this ready post I said you can make
letters out of banners and I'm like okay
that's epic so I'm gonna try and do that
it could be another troll who knows at
this point but I'm willing to get
trolled if the result is what I want
okay we need four of them and I made
five for some reason I know Sven I know
and then when you yell the yellow die so
if I do this can I do letters how do I
do letters through this
it must be spent I swear to god you're
gonna give me a heart attack sit down
sit boy sit how you doing today water
sheep wake up what a shame like this
this is nice yeah it is okay cool and
then a K wouldn't that truly be and like
that and then like that like that I
think you know where this is going yeah
and then an e wouldn't naturally be
we're gonna put that on top of there I
think I think that would look good it
won't be symmetric there though cuz it's
only three wide is there anywhere
there's four wide I need cemetry one two
three four that's five and then it goes
to three ah it won't be symmetric okay I
got it I got it this is how we'll solve
this problem it's it's a little
confusing one needs to enter
to know which level you are on okay I'm
sorry oh god I should not bring fan up
here so bad no I keep forgetting see oh
god if sweat balls so yes
ah okay okay all right now
God sent for the love of God do not fall
down from here what are you yes that's
awesome what do you think sweat okay
that worked that really well
IKEA Tower so beautiful it's going
across the clouds so and remember if
you're ever lost just look for a Kia
Tower and you'll find your way back home
okay how are you doing today you're
against Megan I'm not talking to you
talking to you
yeah yeah you just want to write
everything it's fine okay so then get in
the boat because we have a new thing you
do need to do so basically I want to
build another house I want to build not
just any house but a japanese-style
house
that's right gamers are you excited for
this Sven I think you are nobody PD PI I
want to be able to definite out like the
game has seized achacha a Kasab whatever
would and it looks really cool and I'm
like that looks nihongo is freak we're
gonna build something out of that so
yeah let's just let's just big Sven I
mean a bit build and let's see what
happened where did virgin toad turtle go
all right maybe virgin toad will come
back alright then we'll make steps here
Bing bong Bing bong bong save the earth
save materials in Minecraft okay so I
need to cut the stone get pretty I want
it to be pretty I want my house to be
pretty judge me sue me
maybe I'm maybe I'm thinking a little
too big here but sometimes you got to
think big to go small big five five it's
five six one two three four five six
seven luckily I have my looks like we
need to do some digging
oh I dig like the wind oh my god I
forgot something
okay we'll do that when I get back I
don't know what it is just building in
Minecraft is so relaxing it's not right
Sven it just makes me happy that's right
as you guys know I love Japan and I
don't care if you call me a weed I'll
build my Japanese house okay that's a
pretty cool runway that's pretty epic
all right let's go back so and it's dark
it's sleep time hard day's work this is
a pretty historical moment gamers I have
a lot of diamond but I haven't really
made a level three diamond pickaxe right
everyone keeps complaining that I don't
use my diamonds but then sums Barnhardt
efficiency for okay game sound likes men
got hit okay if bishops before what is
efficiency do oh woe it gain fortune
three on breaking three oh my god that's
that big man I can't wait to test this
out I just test it out a second don't
talk to bait all right that wasn't that
cool ah sorry Sven you have to swim yeah
hey look you're not a bad swimmer oh
he's so happy look at this a cashier
would it's looking so Smacks
so stylish right Sven
oh yeah I don't know what I'm doing this
could turn out really badly
we'll see listen it's all about the
respect so and remember that never
forget it you know this would be a lot
easier
help me bad I wanted to look pretty I
guess this is a good time for me to
share some like embarrassing stories
stuff like that there's a lot of people
a lot of people seem to think my first
video was in Minecraft video so everyone
is like oh my god you should go back to
your roots and play Minecraft I never
actually like played Minecraft I think I
had one series okay that was it like
okay sorry I got it wrong basically my
first video technically that is up on my
channel is a Minecraft video but it
wasn't the first video I uploaded I have
a lot of videos that I just took down
because I think they're just so cringy
and I don't like them I mean I could
probably put them back now I don't
really care anymore but I do I yes
they're cranky none of my videos can be
cranky oh no I misspoke basically the
actual first video that no one has ever
seen
I've tried desperately to find it I
can't find it the very first video that
I ever recorded was a Minecraft video
and it was like before minecraft was
getting popular I know I keep like ooh
I'm a veteran but literally no one
played Minecraft at this point and I
thought okay well wouldn't it be cool to
become like a Minecraft and here we are
nine years later well basically I
thought it was so weird to record a
video like that whole concept was just
so weird to me no one recorded videos at
this time it wasn't like Let's Plays
wasn't popular people weren't doing
minecraft stuff and I was just so
weirded out by I'm like who am I talking
to I have literally no audience am I
supposed to talk to people like there is
one I guess it was really confusing and
weird to make videos when no one else
really was
all right minority I would say compared
to now it's like people aspire to be
youtuber well as before people didn't
really know what importance that was my
point
so I actually upload it to this website
that like posts videos and I thought
okay cool I'll just ask these guys to
help load the video and they'll take
care of it and then that that way I'll
actually have an audience if they post
it but obviously they never posted it
and I couldn't find the video so I don't
have it anymore but my very very very
very first video I have ever recorded
was indeed a minecraft let's play that's
right
that wasn't really what I was getting at
my main point was that oh god this won't
work will it ah Frankie have I built
this all on a step wrong ah oh maybe we
can make like an optical illusion like
these are on the right floor just places
in front and then we get the effect that
we want genius I also liked when I was
starting out doing YouTube videos I was
in a really weird time where I didn't
know what I was I wanted to do I talked
about this a lot so I I applied for like
different jobs and stuff like that and
one of the jobs I actually applied for
I've never told anyone this ok this is
super secret I applied for a job at
Mojang Mojang if you leak my email I
will tell you I probably said something
like hey I know Photoshop you want to
hire me Mojang is the creator of
Minecraft basically and I remember when
they they got really big they they sent
out a like a Twitter's thing or
something saying like oh we're hiring
you can apply and I'm like alright that
would be cool I'm from Sweden it's a
Swedish company I didn't get the job
[Laughter]
imagine if I did that we're getting
under attack Spanish we're building a
Japanese house and you're not allowed I
want to create like this typical
Japanese door effect I don't really know
how to do it I'm hoping that it will
look good with like a trap door yeah
that looks good oh yeah this is a gamer
moments when this is starting to look
epic starting to look Nihon I think yes
not you missed out man
could have made epic games together I
don't hate it it looks a bit alien
I don't know but actually alright we
need more trapdoors I don't really know
how to do the ceiling but we'll figure
it out soon so these doors will not
actually work I know I like it I like it
we went in some midsummer the movie
yesterday which is base of this Swedish
tradition that we have oh boy was that a
trip now that was a film undeniably a
film I recommend it was good I love how
all the colors come together ceiling
time do I build a ceiling in white or a
gray or a cache up now this is a really
gamer question I know that you've been
thinking it throughout its beauty by
gonna make it Alka I'll try the chords
first is I think I can make them in
slams I know I know I'm crazy I'm crazy
Sven game I gotta do what give me gonna
do stone will look good too they could
all look good okay I have an idea why
don't we just test it will test
everything now what looks better
I think the stone I think the stone
looks better it ties it all nice
together
don't you agree Sven I just love
Japanese architecture it's so different
from anything else how will I do that
typical effect where it goes up right I
mean that look doesn't look bad
thanks man no no oh thank god all right
I'm going back to sleep gamers let's go
back and take a nap spin yes
see that's yeah that looks good gamer
moment right there gosh I didn't think
the ceiling would be this complicated
it's really tricky building ceilings no
one talks about that in Minecraft my god
why am i spending so my time on the
problem is I can't just back up and look
how it looks like I have to look at it
at the micro scale and then get a mic
macro picture of it it's really tricky
tricky D get off my house my Japanese
house is for me only
ah let me build this a time god I just
want to build it building houses in
Minecraft is relaxing they said okay
it's looking pretty neat I think it's
all about that details now the fun stuff
we're gonna make some fan nourishment
it's gonna be epic it's like red banners
could look cool maybe black banners
could look cool maybe like a lot of
stuff to look cool I know what I'm doing
no I don't I just hope it looks cool oh
my god turtle virgin turtle is back guys
oh I have together I'm trying to build
oh yeah yeah that's what I want to do
I'm trying to build over here guys
please
oh god we're bouncing we're bouncing so
apparently you can ride these horses
underwater I don't know if that's true
sorry Savannah I gotta check this out
okay alright that's kind of Awesome
what okay you got a sink though oh god
I'm actually drowning can you not drown
me please thank you now what color
scheme am I going
plus I have a lot more red and maybe
I'll do like a cool pattern oh yeah
that's gonna look good I was like here
barging toad okay so I need to see grass
I think you use shears to retrieve it
chip-chop chip top six top chip top why
is the horse eating it lit what an idiot
ah alright it's a secret alright virgin
oh my god he found someone he found
someone okay this is perfect yeah
follow me akima sha Tata
so we need to get them saying but we
have sand here oh this is just perfect
come here guys why are you so hey did I
tell you to stop oh god no you have a
girlfriend come on come on it's like
slightest get up get up get up
did I tell you to stop I need you to eat
it so you two can Frick
I need your helmet from your babies dude
I got to say bone horse is pretty good
like he doesn't disappear and stuff no
one leaves these beach until you two
have friend let that be clear now our
was sight yes
epic mansion alright we're gonna be
there great now we ran out of fence I
hope you guys are happy
oh yeah another thing apparently name
there's another Easter egg if you name
your animal dinner bomb I think can I do
that I'm sorry I'm sorry what do you eat
what are you course I'm so stupid I have
to put a name on it first
my anvil disappeared this better be
worth it where'd he go nothing you could
see oh my oh my no I ruin him better
bode this history
[Laughter]
why did you tell me to do this I'm so
sorry the nine year olds told me to do
it I'm already dead and you Jesus
okay yeah yeah yeah this reminds me
there's another thing I want there's so
many things to do in Minecraft literally
this let's play could go on forever I'm
not even joking okay so with nine slime
balls this hook better be worth it I can
make a slime block and then with a slime
block where it's meant I want sin to see
this then you have to come look at this
why is he upside down I don't know he's
like don't tell me I don't think oh my
god I'm so ticklish
stop it stop it are you oh yeah go in
the pool spin so apparently if I put
this I will be able to bounce watch this
thing yeah okay
so then you try it come here dinnerbone
please damn it looks pretty epic from a
distance I'm not gonna lie alright are
you two ready to make some babies I
think this one is already pretty does
that make any sense you're already
pregnant you where's your babies then
maybe it's your brother or something
God he's like that's my cousin what's
wrong with you main well I guess virgin
toad will be forever a virgin turtle I
keep saying toad you're gonna be here
you're gonna be alone for a long time
I'm sorry I don't know how to break the
news for you I know it looks amazing
Sven I know I worked hard on it but it
was definitely worth it when are we
moving in well we got to do the interior
in stops when you see it's not
completely it just said what kind of
pattern can we do on the banner that
will look cool okay all right wait here
virgin well said you gotta come see this
the miracle of birth is that what I
think it is I knew you were pranking
he's all about
[Music]
what is this yeah oh my god I can't wait
for them to hatch I'm don't worry I'm
not gonna do anything bad yo let's get
the virgin over oh we got to protect
them we got to protect the eggs Oh God
and the Sun is going down oh my god I'm
freaking out I'm freaking out but look I
got a protector I'm so proud of you
turtle
oh god it's a raid put the kegs at all
cost I didn't think you had it in yet
what can I say I was wrong you're gonna
smell again you better protect those
eggs so back basically the zombies will
attack and stomp over the exit they get
the chance so we got to make sure that
these eggs are under our Khan Chaka laka
all right I'm gonna clear out these sand
no back off back off
defend the eggs at all cost I hate them
[Music]
not a creeper not a creeper not a
creeper I'm done
[Music]
if the egg is cracked I'm gonna just
swim bone cow yet don't mind me I'm just
drowning is whatever oh my god I
protected the egg oh thank god
I mean I lost 30 levels but I've
protected the eggs rights men all right
how is the baby's going how are the
babies doing so I could be crazy but I
think if you combine with bone meat you
can actually make this go faster and
yeah I'm crazy okay that doesn't work
sorry sorry I I'm not touching them I
swear I'm not touching them god I love
this shovel I'll have to repair it
okay more sand more area - Frick am i
right ladies
why did I say that okay so all right now
we're just gotta learn this either the
Virgin toto
you can't just have people time with a
girl and then just leave her all right
you got to take responsibility now
virgin turtle oh my god why did the
other one okay what are you two doing
come here
get up look how badly he wants that the
other one made it up here making another
baby
just making another baby you can't just
make it at the same spot you soon
whoa
childbirth come back and take
responsibility
this guy just freaks and bounces push
push push you and push push push push
push push push there will be no more
freaking and bouncing there will just be
freaky - ha ha ha
better I have you trapped now hey calm
down calm down calm down calm down calm
down
alright your bit your bit aggressive
over there I don't know what this is I
don't think this is I think he might be
maybe having kids are stressful guys I
don't know if you knew this
oh my God look at his aam be no no I'm
sorry I'm furious
alright there's only one thing to do and
that's more freaking oh you die miracle
of birth be born
I want that Turtle helmet dude certain
zombie fortress because I want to blow
that thing up okay I'm with they're
gonna pay for what they did this is not
okay should have protected you guys but
I didn't I let you down I could be crazy
and this could be the worst mistake of
my life but I think if you have silk
touch you can separate the eggs oh god
yes it work turtle egg is mine and then
we can place them away from each other
and that way they grow quicker look at
that alright more frickin but I tell you
to stop more frickin meanwhile I can
build my house yeah I didn't see you
there little schmuck I'll kill all of
the younglings now you killed my
younglings I kill your younglings
usually I feel bad about it but not
anymore this is how wars are made this
is how they start I tell you to stop
freaking I don't think so what what what
how science does not allow this
to build my god damn Japanese house keep
fracking
Sven hurry spender look look look the
miracle of life has happened Sam yes oh
my god you've gotta come see this one
hey let me open up for you buddy look
they're tight they're escaping oh god we
gotta wait wait wait wait guys no
outside I think not
oh god I'm wasting precious material do
they need to go to the water addict a
climb that makes no sense
push push sorry little dirt those push
push I'm proud of you Virgin toad I'm
drunk them proud of you what can I say I
didn't think you had it in yet there
will be no baby turtles escaping on my
watch
Sven buddy it's stop Spence op that
oh god I got in front of merging toad I
can't believe it what an absolute
elephant alright gamers this is it for
this week's episode of Minecraft alright
it's not it's not finished but I'm a
pretty pleased with it I think it's it's
gonna come out pretty nice isn't that
right Sven I know this wasn't the most
eventful episode but next time we'll get
on some adventure because I have a
woodland Explorer man see you tomorrow
gamers smash like and buy merch buy what
you never played super simulator
you know it's fun right I'm not supposed
to give my opinion but give it a try and
then you can tell me if it's good or not
not convinced yet okay I'll cut you a
deal the game is available for free and
that's a great price
[Music]